it was an honor to fly you jeffy
[Applause]
hey
rico
listen cesar here
he doesn't spend much time around people
not anymore
this is the secret agent
see this is rico villa says you have
something to show me
proof
proof that none of the weather occurring
in solis is natural
come on back i've got to
put that there
uh just one minute and i'll have this
i've been looking for that
okay right here
okay
remember cesar stick to what we talked
about cece okay okay
all right
the tornado that hit nueva was the
capital ten years ago
meena bendual a few months later
my plane
all destroyed by tornadoes
tornadoes controlled by
the reptilians
say sir or the nordics but i've
definitely ruled out the greys
no abductions stay star
wait wait wait wait wait
watch
this
how'd you explain that huh
appears out of nowhere and moments later
a tornado forms around it look familiar
play that again
you've seen it too haven't you
go
on i
i seen it
here
and here this is near yappa and this is
on a trace
a weather research facility
both japa and sonatres are funded by
oscar espanol the man behind it all if
he even is a man
let's assume he is a man
do you think this ufo is a core we could
use to hack into the apple network if we
can get to it see
impossible
it's inside a tornado
what if i dive
down
dive
down
into the eye of a tornado
so
how do we make it happen
i say we start with this
[Music]
let's go over one more time bien
okay
we need to trap and grow a tornado to do
that
we need the wind cannons from the alien
weather labs
to steal it to the capitol
to know where to place the wind cannon i
will use the router equipment aroho
now we'll need to follow and track the
tornado i'll try the storm chaser to
build the storm chaser see see we need
to bring some of the alien weather
tracking equipment from the alien
weather lab
and when the time is right the army
disables the wind cannons protecting
minavende
that will allow the tornado to go
towards nueva boss
which the army will evacuate
build a perimeter of wind cannons
and we grow the tornado there until it's
big enough then i jump in on cesar
suffolk and do
something
what do we
[Laughter]
he's think nuts
and this way
he's gonna work
you